hi I'm Erik Bosse and a quiet place is
one of my favorite horror films in
recent years directed by and starring
John Krasinski the movie follows a
family of survivors in a world where
blind alien creatures hunt humans
through sound forcing his family to
communicate with sign language and walk
around like hobbits on sand covered
paths and avoid eating their popcorn too
loudly guys sitting behind me seriously
if you haven't seen it already you gotta
see this movie in a theater sound design
is just nothing like I've ever seen or
heard but rather than just reviewing
everything I loved about this movie I'm
gonna address some of the questions they
might have had the ending the creatures
backstory the families decisions sequel
rumors and yeah spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the movie yet okay let's
get started with the first question what
are the monsters the monsters in this
movie have no given name everything we
know about them comes from notes and
newspaper clippings and Abbot's basement
and of course the way the creatures
stalk and kill people
we know they are extraterrestrial one
headline says invasion with images of
meteors crashing all over the earth Lee
wrote on his dry erase board that they
hunt in packs and why don't they eat
their prey suggesting these beans are
way beyond mere survival they're trying
to exterminate the other noise-making
species and turn earth into their own
natural soundscape other headlines
describe them as indestructible with one
of Lee's notes on his dry erase board
saying armor question mark suggesting
they could have some kind of
biomechanical exoskeletal protective
layer against human weapons and of
course the creatures are blind with
highly sensitive auditory organs that
detect noise even a single word spoken
out loud or a footstep that crunches too
heavily on the leaves the designers of
this movie use lots of real-life animals
to inspire these creatures the creatures
make clicking noises for echolocation a
detail pulled from bats the designers
also said that they looked at
prehistoric fish black snakes as well as
bog people human corpses that have been
mummified in Pete's turning the skin
black and giving it a sagging leathery
look and giving me a new thing to be
terrified of they also mentioned the
Nautilus a sea mollusk with bad vision
their organs are contained within a
protective shell similar to these
creatures but the filmmakers still one
of the creatures to look vaguely
humanoid so they also pulled inspiration
from the Xenomorphs of alien and you can
definitely see that in the odd angles of
the
Penda jizz and the aggressive rows of
sharp teeth now some are pointing out
the design parallels to the demagogue
and of stranger things which yeah it
does feature these opening flaps of the
head revealing the red flesh underneath
really it was important to the VFX
artists for the creatures and organs to
look gross and medical and raw the way
human guts or brains would look which
brings us to our next question what is
the monsters weakness exactly now this
is a central question posed by the movie
itself written among Lee's notes and as
a movie a quiet place cleverly uses the
creatures own strength as their weakness
for one using sound to hunt gives these
creatures quite a few blind spots loud
natural sounds like a roaring waterfall
cover any nearby quieter sounds
providing a safe haven from them the
creatures can also be drawn away by
other louder noises like egg timers and
fireworks most of all sensitivity to
amplified frequencies weakens them which
is what we see in the final scene the
families daughter Regan is deaf and
throughout the movie Lee attempts to
build from scratch cochlear implants for
Regan which I know you can pronounce it
either cochlear cochlear I'm gonna go
with cochlear cuz it makes me giggle
which never worked because Lee is a
self-taught medical engineer using
scavenge supplies unlike a hearing aid
which amplifies sound for the
hard-of-hearing
a cochlear implant bypasses the normal
hearing process it's inserted inside the
cochlea and uses electrical energy to
stimulate the auditory nerve and the
specific frequency of this mount bunk
Shimane cochlear implant disrupts the
auditory nerve of these creatures it
happens on accident a few times with
Regan until the ending when the family
is cornered in the basement and she
turns it back on and presses it against
Lee's microphone the creature freaks out
close up show its outer shell on its
appendages wrinkling and fidgeting as
his head flaps go berserk until it
collapses and it jumps back up exposing
its vital organs and allows Evelyn Emily
Blunt to blast those organs with a
shotgun killing it and then that sound
Larssen more creatures seen on the
security monitors laden Regan to crank
Lee's microphone all the way up to 11
preparing to destabilize all the
creatures in the nearby area as Evelyn
pumps a shotgun like a badass and this
ending answers a few other questions you
might have had like how could this
family survive when the rest of the
world couldn't a quiet place is really
effective at avoiding those sci-fi
horror movie tropes
like one family saves the planet well
first we know that
abbit family isn't the only survivors of
this every day at sundown remember lead
lights at orchha top is great silo
signaling to a dozen others in the area
but for the Abbott's to devise an actual
weapon against the creatures succeeding
where the US military and all the
militaries around the world failed it
still makes sense because their oldest
child Regan is deaf when the invasion
hit they had already been using various
forms of nonverbal communication that
made them better fit for survival
only less than 1% of the population is
deaf giving the abbot's a very uncommon
advantage and that advantage which of
course was disguised as a weakness was
the thing that led to leads construction
of all these cochlear implants that
would later be used as a weapon against
the creatures nervous systems also we
don't know if the abbot's even survived
two of the six of them died in this
movie and for the remaining four at the
end lots of creatures were headed that
way who knows how much ammo Evelyn had
in that shotgun the movies cut to black
endings suggest the fight but not
necessarily survival and now we come to
perhaps the biggest question at least I
had why did the family choose to get
pregnant and about you but when I saw
emily Blunt's womb after the cut forward
and time i was like seriously you
couldn't wrap it up Big Tuna gonna bring
a screaming baby into this world nah
come out with o2 gas every day and put
him in a box for who knows how many
years now I don't think this pregnancy
was an accident
the Abbott's the risk that pregnancy
brings into their lives speaks to the
fiber of their character sure they're
cautious and practical in all other ways
but that doesn't make them paranoid
Hermits they still sit down for family
dinners they pray they teach their kids
math they go out on foraging expeditions
and yes they continue to grow their
family with another child Evelyn's jokes
with Marcus about dying an old woman
they believe in their futures so rather
than seeing Beau's death as a warning to
turn inward and fear they view it as a
missed opportunity to prove themselves
as survivors and protectors oh we can't
protect right after giving birth to her
new son Evelyn tells Leigh I could have
held him now the line is a misdirect
she's not referring to the baby but to
bow on the day he died she could have
held him on the walk back to their home
now Evelyn just gave birth but she's
playing woulda coulda shoulda with the
last kid clearly she sees this new son
this her second chance to survive on her
turns so this baby while super
impractical in this world is this movies
beating heart and from a narrative
standpoint a pregnancy is one hell of a
ticking time bomb and before I go one
final question what will happen in the
sequel the screenwriters Brian Woodson
scott beck said that they were totally
open to a sequel saying it's a fun world
and there are so many other things he
can do hinting at a ton of scene ideas
that they couldn't fit in the movie and
they indicated any sequel wouldn't
follow the Abbott family necessarily
perhaps opening things up to other
survivors in this alien invaded world
now that sounds similar to like a
Cloverfield extended universe
interesting you should bring that up the
writers said that a quiet place was
briefly considered to be part of
Paramount's Cloverfield series but the
writers preferred it to be its own story
in world and here's hoping any future
quiet place movies go further in this
direction specifically when it comes to
the movies bold sound design
apparently woods and Beck's original
script for this movie only had one line
of dialogue I would love to see a
quieter place live up to its title but a
question for you guys what was your
biggest jump scare in a quiet place for
me it wasn't even one of the creatures
whose freaking Emily Blunt just slap in
a bloody hand against a shower stall
door oh god there's gotta be a better
way to get his attention right comment
down below with your thoughts or tweet
me directly at ei vas and follow new
rockstars on Twitter for updates on our
videos like and share this video and
subscribe the new rock stars for more
analysis and deep dives and movies you
love we've done similar explainers for
stranger things and annihilation and it
and get out now you get out of here but
thanks for watching bye